[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans
audition publique très heureuse de vous
retrouver pour une heure de débat sur
les chaînes parlementaires alors dans
moins d'une demi-heure le chef de l'État
va prendre la parole pour tenter
d'apaiser le pays demain la première
ministre qui fête ses 1 an à Matignon
reçoit aussi elle est syndicats pour
renouer le dialogue mais dans le pays
forcée de constater que et bien le
climat reste tendu comme ici à
l'Assemblée en partie à cause d'un petit
groupe d'irréductible Gaulois
réfractaires aurait pu dire Emmanuel
Macron Bertrand pencher bonsoir merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation alors
on vous connaît pas très bien tout ça
pour ceux qui ne vous connaissent pas
encore et bien vous êtes le président du
groupe lyaute c'est-à-dire le groupe
liberté indépendance outre-mer et
territoires un groupe de députés
hétéroclite qui appartient à
l'opposition sans aucun doute puisque
vous êtes à l'initiative d'une
proposition de loi qui sera débattue le
8 juin dans l'hémicycle pour abroger la
réforme des retraites et revenir à un
âge de départ à 62 ans vous êtes le
troubl de cette hémicycle alors on va
revenir assez longuement sur cette
actualité avec Tam trany ma conseillère
de Public Sénat dans quelques instants
ensuite vous retrouverez Yves réars et
Vincent roux du Figaro et du Figaro live
et puis enfin le député Renaissance
Charles instant school nous rejoindra
pour le dernier quart d'heure de cette
émission il veut également vous
interpeller et bien sûr votre
responsabilité sur la réforme des
retraites alors justement et bien le
président a fustigé le président de la
République a fustigé les oppositions à
cette réforme des retraites dans une
interview ça ne vous a sûrement pas
échappé à l'opinion Bertrand penchere
est-ce que vous êtes dans un déni de
réalité sur l'équilibre de retraite
comme le dit le président dans cette
interview de réalité en tout cas nous
sommes ni dans un déni social ni dans un
déni politique nous sommes face à une
très vaste crise sociale et politique
dans notre dans notre pays
nous sommes dans une démocratie ce qui
n'échappe pas personne mais curieusement
dans une démocratie ou jusque près
jusqu'à présent le Parlement n'a jamais
été amené à se prononcer et nous voulons
sortir de cette démocratie c'est aussi
la Constitution et c'est aussi le 49-3
oui c'est la Constitution c'est aussi le
49-3 sauf que le 49-3 on n'a pas été on
n'a pas été enfin on s'est prononcé pour
ou contre le renversement du
gouvernement nous n'avons pas voté nous
n'avons même pas discuté compris cette
article 7 de la Constitution concernant
l'allongement de l'âge légal de départ à
la retraite à cause de l'obstruction des
oppositions peut-être à cause du 47,1
d'un article qu'on a retrouvé dans la
Constitution que le Conseil
constitutionnel aurait dû sanctionner si
ça avait été une vraie cours
constitutionnelle mais chacun sait que
le Conseil constitutionnel lit la
Constitution mais prend aussi des
décisions politiques nous sommes dans un
déni dans un déni politique ici dans ce
pays et nous voulons simplement faire en
sorte que le Parlement se prononce s'il
y a déjà pas d'obstruction et si on au
Parlement de se prononcer ce sera une
première victoire et si évidemment une
majorité de parlementaires vote notre
proposition de loi qui est pas une
proposition de loi révolution
le président de la République dit dans
cette même interview c'est une
proposition de loi à 15 milliards
finalement est-ce que c'est pas un déni
de réalité de ne pas voir que dans les
années qui viennent il y aura pas
d'équilibre financiers sur ce truc
d'abord que c'est très assez gonflé de
la part du président de la République a
augmenté la dette de 600 milliards
d'euros à travers certes la crise du
covid et la
crise énergétique mais on aurait pu
dépenser autrement autrement qui a
chaque année creusé de 50 milliards de
plus les déficits parce que les remises
budgétaires mal ciblées coûtent 50
milliards d'euros par an au budget de
l'État nous dire que
nous prenons pas nos responsabilités
nous prenons nos responsabilités c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous avons
souhaité faire en sorte qu'il y ait une
conférence sociale qui traite ce sujet à
travers des propositions c'est 15
milliards d'euros je rappelle quand même
que le budget des retraites c'est plus
de 300 milliards d'euros il faut trouver
15 milliards d'euros à l'horizon 2030
nous avons fait des propositions on va y
revenir d'ailleurs assez longuement avec
ta nuit dans quelques instants en tout
cas c'est irresponsable de passer en
force parce que cette crise sociale elle
est violente cette crise politique elle
est toute autant moi j'ai pas envie que
le pays se déstabilise et j'attire votre
attention sur le fait que si on vient
récemment dégrader la note de la France
c'est simplement parce que l'opinion
publique internationale médusait
constate que cette grande démocratie est
notre pays est en incapacité de réformer
parce qu'on est en incapacité dialoguer
et de trouver ensemble les solutions
pour ne pas être dégradé à nouveau il
faut évidemment faire des réformes mais
il faut faire des réformes en dialoguant
en discutant en entraînant l'opinion
publique et on entraînant les corps
intermédiaires sinon ça s'appelle du
passage en force et le passage en force
après passage en force ça mais ça c'est
générateur des gilets jaunes demain
d'autres crises moi je pense que notre
pays doit et peut se réformer par le
dialogue la concertation et le débat
à l'Assemblée ce que vous avez le
sentiment que tout est figé jusqu'au 8
juin donc date à laquelle vous allez
pouvoir défendre votre proposition de
loi je sais pas si tout est figé en tout
cas je constate que ce gouvernement est
de plus en plus en incapacité de
gouverner avec des projets de loi qui
ont déporté quand même très très
médiocre on est tétanisé à l'idée de de
réformer notre pays on était tétanisé à
l'idée de réformes et notre pays parce
qu'on n'a pas tenu compte du fait que
nous étions dans une majorité relative
et si nous avions fonctionné comme dans
tous les parlements avec de la
proportionnelle on aurait passé un mois
de mois trois mois six mois pour faire
en sorte que les groupes parlementaires
se mettent d'accord sur des réformes
essentielles ça veut dire une coalition
et c'est pas trop dans l'esprit français
on a une majorité relative il faut se
mettre d'accord sur les propositions les
plus importantes pour le pays nous
sommes un groupe parlementaire
d'opposition mais aussi de proposition
nous avons des propositions pour faire
avancer notre pays
vous allez les confronter avec d'autres
et il y a pas de raison qu'on ne trouve
pas des solutions moi je suis à la tête
d'un groupe parlementaire excusez-moi du
peu où il y a des anciens socialistes
des socio-démocrates jusqu'aux UDA en
passant par des Outre-mer on y dit vous
êtes un groupe hétéroclite mais
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette histoire
on est un groupe qui sait dialoguer
discuter on a la clé de la réussite la
clé de la réussite c'est le dialogue
entre nous pourquoi est-ce que nous
faisons entre nous nous pourrions pas le
faire
de la République en lui disant dialoguer
vous voyez nous on y arrive au groupe
les autres donc faites-le plus largement
il sembler
ce qui est important c'est pas un
président de la République avec une
cervelle puissance 10 c'est un président
de la République avec des grandes
oreilles pour écouter c'est pas la
taille du cerveau qui compte c'est la
taille des oreilles alors ma concert de
Public Sénat nous a rejoint sur ce
plateau bonsoir tam-tra nuit bonsoir et
vous aviez donc une question sur la
proposition loi du groupe liotte sur les
retraites à Bertrand pencher et oui tous
les yeux sont focalisés bien sûr sur le
8 juin date à laquelle votre proposition
de loi doit être examiner d'ailleurs
est-ce que vous avez un doute sur le
fait qu'elle le soit bien le 8 juin
toujours des doutes ce qui est important
c'est que les parlementaires qui sont
contre cette loi se mobilise après
chacun agira en responsabilités
il y a une manifestation importante le
si le 6 juin
oui oui
on ne sait jamais je rappelle quand même
que notre mot de la motion de censure a
failli passer à ne le voit près on sait
pas se résultat à la vraie dire bon ça
veut dire que il manque encore 9 comme
on ne voit pour pour changer la donne en
matière de retraite bon la notion de
censure les abstentionnistes se
prononcent pas je pense que certains qui
vont être gênés que la majorité soit en
train de d'agir justement pour faire en
sorte que votre texte ne soit pas
débattu vous avez
signé un courrier aujourd'hui vous
interpeller sur vos inquiétudes sur le
fait que même manœuvre veulent parler de
10 recevabilité financières autour de
votre texte oui parce que si pour ne pas
passer un texte de loi on s'en prend au
fondements démocratique c'est-à-dire en
parlement qui est en incapacité de
légiférer je peux vous dire qu'on allume
le bâton de dynamite et je pense que ça
sera encore pire de ne pas voter que
pour le gouvernement et la majorité
relative se faire renvoyer un texte sous
la majorité des paramètres sont contre
donc je il y a une verte si on ne va pas
jusqu'au jusqu'à l'examen du texte c'est
un bâton de dynamique mais ça serait
dramatique pour la démocratie vous
rendez compte mais les recevabilité elle
peut pas être soulevée dans le cas de
cette réforme des retraites quand le
président dit ça coûte 15 milliards
c'est recevable financièrement il y a
jamais eu aucune proposition de loi par
des propositions de loi des projets de
loi vie des professions de loi venant
des parlementaires on leur a jamais
demandé de faire accompagner tout ça par
des recettes par une recette équivalente
1 ça s'est jamais fait dans notre
histoire donc est-ce qu'on veut changer
est-ce qu'on veut changer est-ce qu'on
veut changer les règles en cours de
route c'est quand même très grave on
n'est pas dans un une démocratie
bananière quoi bananière démocratie
ils invoquaient l'article 40 sur votre
proposition de loi évidemment on va pas
marcher en permanence et bricoler brique
fabricoler bricoler notre commande notre
fonctionnement donc moi ça me paraît ça
me paraît invraisemblable que ce cas est
deuxièmement deuxièmement qu'est-ce
qu'on dit à travers cette proposition de
loi nous prenons nos responsabilités 1
on revient sur cette augmentation de
l'âge légal de la départ à la retraite
parce que c'est injuste je suis allé
faire mes courses chez Auchan la semaine
dernière la caissière me dit écoutez 67
ans ils sont fous
et elle partira peut-être plus tôt aussi
la caissière elle a peut-être commencé
plus tôt et elle partira peut-être plus
tôt la cave tu vois ce n'est pas
je vais ensuite le lendemain acheter des
plats préparés chez mon boucher qui me
dit je dois partir en septembre je sais
pas quand je vais partir et je discute
avec la responsable de la Carsat qui me
dit ça fait 20 ans que je travaille à la
Carsat la caisse de retraite j'ai jamais
vu une réforme aussi précipitée de
l'opposition des Français mais si on en
revient à l'Assemblée nationale pour
l'instant le texte a été déclaré
recevable par le Bureau de l'Assemblée
qu'est-ce qui peut se passer qu'est-ce
que vous craignez qu'il se passe au
niveau de la de la majorité pour qu'il
puisse essayer de déclarer le texte qui
recevable
on peut on peut tout imaginer avec eux
vous avez il nous avait promis juré
crachait parole de scout qu'on allait
pas avoir
49-3 ils ont tué le 49-3 bon euh
des tas d'amendements il peut y avoir de
l'obstruction parlementaire de la
parlotte comment de la parlotte à tous
les lignes de la parlotte à tous les
niveaux donc je pense vraiment que
il est vraiment indispensable qui est
pas d'obstruction parlementaire parce
que je pense que le remède serait pire
que le mal
alors je voudrais vous faire réagir à ce
qu'a dit la première ministre la semaine
dernière elle a dit c'est assez
irresponsable de leur part elle part
elle parle de vous de laisser croire que
leur démarche permettra de revenir sur
la réforme des retraites cette
proposition de loi est une façon
d'attirer la lumière en disant pas la
vérité aux Français qu'est-ce que vous
lui répondez et est-ce que vous mentez
aux Français en leur laissant croire que
votre texte pourrait réellement abroger
la réforme des retraites moi je pense
que le gouvernement le président de la
République et la majorité relative ils
sont dans une peur panique et qu'ils
utilisent tous les arguments pour
effrayer les uns et les autres et nous
décrédibiliser est-ce qu'il est
irresponsable que le Parlement se
prononce on élu au suffrage universel
direct si les représentants du peuple ne
peuvent pas se prononcer dans quel pays
dans quelle démocratie sommes-nous vous
êtes aussi dans un groupe politique dans
un coup médiatique avec cette
proposition de loi mais pourquoi un coup
médiatique un coup politique si nous
nous si une majorité de députés se
prononce contre ce système de réforme
des retraites tel qu'il a le cheminement
démocratique de la réforme des retraites
il a déjà eu lieu Bertrand pencher il
est terminé ce cheminement démocratique
un moment on a discuté de cet article 7
devenu article 10 de la con de sur
l'augmentation de l'âge légal de départ
c'est quand même c'est quand même fort
de café que les députés se que les
députés se fanent se prononcent pas et
moi je pense que si les députés se
prononcent ça sera un séisme politique
et je pense que ça aidera d'ailleurs le
président Macron à sortir de cette crise
sociale et politique voyez qui peut plus
sortir sans être camouflé avec vous
voulez l'aider en fait à sortir de la
crise démocratique avec
bon il puisse gouverner le pays c'est
quatre prochaines années intelligemment
en se disant que je me suis trompé bah
il y a pas on peut aussi faire connaître
des erreurs je me suis trompé on va pas
passer en force on va l'aider à trouver
des solutions et que vous allez voir que
pendant quatre ans on va bien travailler
pour notre pays alors au fond est-ce que
vous pensez qu'elle peut être votée
cette proposition de loi oui
c'est-à-dire que tous vos alliés qui ont
été consignés donc qui ont signé la
nuque par exemple vous pensez que vous
ferez le plein de voix à gauche de
l'extrême droite jusqu'à
les filles je pense que des parents
les les parlementaires républicains il y
en avait il y en a 19 qui ont voté la
motion de censure quand même un acte
fort j'imagine pas que les
parlementaires qui ont voté l'émotion de
censure ne viennent pas voter cette
cette
propositions
qui sont pas déplacés qui m'ont dit bah
si on avait su on l'aurait fait bon on
me dit qu'il y aurait à peu près 25
parlementaires LR contre cette réforme
il y en a beaucoup qui vont s'abstenir
bon vous rajoutez tout ça donc je pense
ça va passer je pense que c'est pas
certain mais ça va passer mais je pense
que vraiment d'abord si nous votons ça
sera la revanche au moins de la
démocratie on pourra regarder nos
électeurs les yeux dans les yeux en leur
disant vous avez vous avez désigné à
l'Assemblée nationale on a tout fait
pour faire passer ce texte on est dans
une démocratie il faut que la démocratie
puisse s'exercer admettons que le texte
soit voté est-ce qu'il y a pas quasiment
aucune chance qu'il soit adopté par le
Sénat le Sénat qui a voté la première
réforme des retraites ou la droite est
majoritaire d'abord un je pense que si
le texte est voté réellement ça sera un
séisme politique et je vois pas le
président Macron ne pas en tenir compte
il y a des décrets d'applications les
organisations
les organisations syndicales que j'ai
reçues CFDT CGT demain je reçois le
président de la Confédération générale
des cadres tout le monde me dit ça va
beaucoup beaucoup de nous aider dans nos
négociations merci et bravo et en tout
cas on a vraiment besoin de et après le
Sénat peut-être pas sans savoir que la
moitié des fins il va y avoir une part
de renouvellement du Sénat la moitié la
moitié
au mois de septembre un deux bon le
texte version du Sénat tel qu'il est
revenu à l'Assemblée nationale a été
particulièrement détricoté notamment la
question de l'emploi des seniors il y
avait une très belle avancée
40% des personnes qui partent à la
retraite sont au chômage on augmente de
2 ans là je départ à la retraite bon
s'il y a pas un vaste plan Seigneur tout
ça est complètement débile
idiot ils ont mis en place un vaste plan
senior qui s'est transformé dans la
commission mixte paritaire par une
petite mesure et qui finalement
complètement était retiré
constitutionnel donc moi je ne désespère
pas que le Sénat puisse s'appuyer
également sur votre épouse certains
sénateurs qui vous disent qui
il y a eu beaucoup de il y avait
beaucoup de sénateurs y compris des
sénateurs centrist le prochemoi il faut
vraiment hésité sur le vote de cette de
commande de cette loi quand elle est
passée au Sénat la moitié du Sénat va
être renouvelée et bien il faut pas bon
faut pas non plus aussi désespérer du
vote du Sénat mais quand même je
rappelle ce qui est l'essentiel si nous
élu au suffrage universel direct nous
nous votons une proposition de loi je ne
vois pas comment plant démocratique le
président de la République
démocratique que la réforme des
retraites qui a été votée et qui est
constitutionnellement
je le rappelle que je rappelle que ce
texte n'a pas permis son cheminement
jusqu'au jusqu'au bout à l'Assemblée
nationale alors vous dites certes
obstruction mais franchement on n'était
pas un mois deux mois près pour discuter
de ce texte ils nous ont sorti cet
article 47 1 de la Constitution que
personne
il aurait fallu plus d'une année pour
tout étudier bien sûr que non bien sûr
que non a déjà eu dans le passé des
textes de loi avec des moi je me
rappelle de Philips
photographier sur je sais pas quel type
de loi avec des piles des pieds d'amour
ça c'est ça c'est réglé ça c'est réglé
on n'était pas à 3 mois 6 mois près pour
travailler sur une proposition un projet
de loi de ce type on a passé outre le
Parlement on a passé toutes les corps
intermédiaires on a passé outre les
manifestations bon et tout le monde se
dit mais pourquoi les gens sont aussi
désabusés veulent plus aller voter ben
moi je vous dis pourquoi on va pas voter
parce que ça sert à rien de voter pour
des parlementaires qui ne s'expriment
pas et bien on veut redonner c'est de
l'aide de noblesse au Parlement et ça
même si le Conseil constitutionnel a
validé l'intégralité de ce cheminement
vous l'entendez j'ai pas la cruauté de
de détailler le mode de nomination du
Conseil constitutionnel rappeler le
nombre de ministres qui ont été nommés
au Conseil constitutionnel rappeler que
le conseil institutionnel n'est pas une
cour constitutionnelle que le Conseil
constitutionnel a passé son temps dans
le passé à une décision dépendante pour
vous c'était pas une décision
indépendante non
pour réformer le Conseil constitutionnel
de remettre en cause une institution
comme le Conseil constitutionnel en
France j'ai le droit de remettre en
cause qui je veux excusez-moi et si les
Françaises et les Français veulent pas
voter pour moi ben ils ne voteront pas
pour moi il y a des choses qui sont
injustes qui sont injustes
une cour constitutionnelle indépendante
dans notre pays comme dans toutes les
démocraties mais cette constitution va
le pré en 1958 tous les pouvoirs au
président de la République
c'est compliqué Bertrand pencher si
cette proposition de loi n'est pas votée
n'est pas adoptée est-ce que c'est la
fin de la séquence des retraites
en tout cas ça sera
il faudra passer effectivement une autre
séquence il faudra aussi que le
Président de la République assume cette
cette impopularité il faudra que le
Président de la République assume
également cette difficulté à travailler
encore pendant 4 ans encore pendant 4
ans et voir un parlement quasiment
paralysé
pour vous c'est la fin de la séquence
c'est la fin du combat c'est la fin du
combat des syndicats aussi
vraisemblablement faudra passer une
autre étape à une autre étape ça réglera
pas la question de la crise démocratique
et du fonctionnement de nos institutions
comme ça bien c'est ce que vous voulez
dire moi vous savez quand j'ai été élu
quand j'ai vu cette majorité relative je
me suis dit c'est génial on va devenir
comme dans n'importe quel Parlement qui
nous entoure on va nous mettre autour
d'une table ça va durer trois mois
quatre mois cinq mois et puis on va
finir par se mettre d'accord comme on le
fait dans nos conseils municipaux comme
on le fait moi j'ai été président de
département 80% des délibérations sont
votes unanimité on sait très peu sur le
budget mais on passe du temps et on
discute vous êtes prêt à négocier vous
vous êtes prêts à voter des textes nous
sommes un groupe d'audition mais aussi
un groupe de propositions nous avons des
propositions à faire sur le plan
économique social environnemental et en
termes de gouvernance et de nouveaux
modes de décision si nos propositions
peuvent être mises à la table de
négociation avec d'autres propositions
nous sommes prêts à travailler dans le
cadre d'une gouvernance future c'est
clair
Inter changer le président penchère sur
les violences contre les élus car
Isabelle borne reçoit mercredi le maire
de Saint-Brévin le maire de Saint-Brévin
qui a démissionné après que sa maison a
été incendie et cela parce qu'il voulait
déplacer un centre d'accueil pour
demander d'asile un cada est-ce que pour
vous l'État a manqué à ses devoirs c'est
ce qui a dénoncé le maire de
Saint-Brévin j'observe que c'est ce
dénoncer le maire de Saint-Brevin je
pense qu'on aurait pu peut-être
davantage le le protéger
notamment face à des propos haineux de
l'extrême droite et je suis dans un
département le gouvernement a failli
aussi le gouvernement enfin je pense que
le gouvernement aurait dû davantage sans
doute davantage protéger le maire c'est
pas facile c'est pas facile moi j'ai
j'ai des maires dans mon département qui
est un département rural des maires qui
sont agressés je pense qu'il y a une
réactivité un peu un peu trop lente en
permanence des pouvoirs publics on
dépose une plainte quand on est en
attendu on est attendu bon le
justiciable mais beaucoup de temps à se
faire à se faire juger c'est c'est une
angoisse c'est quand même très très
compliqué de multiplication par deux des
violences faites aux élus depuis 2 ans
et c'est ce que vous observez vous ici
sur sur le terrain et comment vous
l'expliquez j'explique tout ça par le le
covid le
le fait que beaucoup de nos concitoyens
se soient repliés sur eux-mêmes il y a
une montée de la de la violence
y compris intra familial j'observe par
exemple
une montée de la violence aussi dans le
débat public et aussi une responsabilité
des violences mais vous savez cette
montée de la violence dans le débat
public elle est elle porte un nom c'est
la c'est cette centralisation du pouvoir
c'est le fait que les contre-pouvoirs ne
fonctionnent pas c'est le fait que la
faute d'Emmanuel Macron on en est là
aujourd'hui si un plus de violence en
tout cas s'il y a plus de violence dans
le débat public oui oui parce que c'est
un problème c'est un problème de de de
débat à partir du moment où on fait en
sorte que les gens ne travaillent pas
ensemble et se font imposer des mesures
par le haut en permanence qu'est-ce
qu'il y a comme autre solution que celle
de manifester alors manifeste puis les
manifestations ça sert à rien moment on
se dit il y a de la violence et puis on
va c'est de l'assurance chair c'est de
l'assurance chair de viande tout ça tout
ça c'est pas tout ça c'est pas possible
est-ce que vous voulez des évolutions
législatives pour bien répondre à cette
violence faite aux élus est-ce que il
faut des dé durcissements des peines
plus dures qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que
vous proposez il y a eu déjà de
nombreuses avancées depuis 2019
condamnation pour les violences aux
personnes détentrices d'autorité
d'autorités
les élus sur ce régime nous avions leur
déposer des amendements dans le sens
puis ça fait fait l'objet de de nombreux
on va dire recevabilité et puis les les
élus qui quand même sont maintenant de
plus en plus suivis par les tribunaux
avec l'aide des procureurs quand ils
sont face à quelqu'un qui est en train
de se faire condamner il faut faire en
sorte que les jugements aient lieu très
rapidement ça peut pas attendre un an
deux ans parce que le maire notamment
milieu rural continue à voir la personne
qui l'agressait face à lui tout ça crée
vraiment des graves problèmes le centre
d'analyse et de
lutte ça peut servir oui c'est utile
mais c'était c'est bien qu'il y ait des
des moyens aussi de les observer c'est
quand même beaucoup mieux de mettre en
place des mesures pour protéger les élus
locaux merci
de nous dans cette émission on poursuit
avec on va prendre la direction du
Figaro live on retrouve Vincent roux il
est ici bonsoir bonsoir Vincent et vous
aviez une question sur volodi mère
dellinski au lendemain de sa visite
éclair à Paris en Europe
oui bonsoir Bertrand pencher
effectivement à volodime zeninski était
aujourd'hui à Londres et je voulais
savoir si vous approuviez la livraison
par la Grande-Bretagne de missiles à
longue portée
à l'Ukraine alors que les autres pays
occidentaux se sont refusés à le faire
parce que livrer des missiles à longue
portée c'est le risque de toucher le
territoire russe et de provoquer une
escalade ou à l'agression russe et
évidemment disproportionné par rapport à
la réaction des Ukrainiens moi je pense
que
il faut donner tous les moyens
d'armement nécessaires nécessaires à
l'Ukraine je pense que la fragilisation
de l'Ukraine c'est une fragilisation de
nos démocraties et de l'Europe moi je
voulais vraiment rendre hommage aux
Ukrainiens par
leur par leur combat j'étais vraiment
très très frappé à peine quelques
semaines
après l'invasion de l'Ukraine les
présidents de groupes parlementaires
avaient été invités par le Premier
ministre de l'époque et le chef
d'état-major des armées à une réunion à
huis clos et le chef d'état-major des
armées je lui ai posé la question
suivante qui était très claire en disant
mon Général
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de l'agression
russe et combien de temps tout ça va
durer et
chef d'état-major des armées me disant
mais vous savez on s'est coordonné un
peu avec tout les chefs d'état-major des
armées Occident enfin de de l'OTAN on
pense que ça va durer quelques semaines
à quelques entre quelques semaines et un
ou deux mois près je le revoyais je le
revoyais juste après je l'ai revu il y a
quelques mois il me dit oui il me dit on
avait vraiment complètement sous-estimé
ce courage énorme des des Ukrainiens et
heureusement qu'il y a eu toute cette
accompagnement militaire mais il faut
davantage accompagner
somme du côté de l'Ukraine et si nous
sommes du côté de l'Ukraine faut
vraiment armer l'Ukraine mais avec des
avions de combat par exemple la France
refuse que la France montre l'exemple
avec des avions de combat parce qu'on
parle d'une coalition éventuellement
avec l'Angleterre il faut savoir ce
qu'on veut savoir ce qu'on veut est-ce
qu'on veut battre va faire en sorte que
l'Ukraine battre batte puisse battre et
chasser l'ennemis russe de son
territoire si c'est oui il faut s'en
donner les il faut s'en donner les
moyens
Vincent
est-ce que est-ce que d'abord on prend
le risque de livrer des armes qui
pourraient provoquer une escalade et
question subsidiaire tous ces moyens
qu'on accorde à l'Ukraine pour l'instant
c'est un prix c'est ça dégarnit et sa
vie de nos munitions oui mais si on perd
face ulkraine perd cette guerre quelles
sont les conséquences il faut regarder
là où est le moindre mal et quand même
et le moindre mal me semble-t-il c'est
de de pouvoir
aider aider l'Ukraine en sorte que
l'Ukraine soit ancré dans la démocratie
que la Russie perde et que ce soit aussi
un message international à toutes ces
puissances qui nous veulent que du mal
et du mal à la démocratie au droit de
l'homme merci Vincent roux et on vous
retrouvera un petit peu plus tard dans
cette émission nous accueillons
ifreart bon soirée
dont j'ai pas la réponse et c'est pour
ça que je vous entendre vous êtes un
homme issu du centre vous êtes parti
radical tout comme d'ailleurs Charles de
Courson qui est issu du centre et je ne
comprends pas comment vous vous pouvez
vous opposer à une réforme que vous
réclamiez sans doute il y a quelques
années notamment Monsieur Charles de
Courson c'est il y a des traces des
archives sont là il était pour la
retraite à 64 ans comment d'un coup
comme ça et bien vous êtes hostile à
cette réforme je répondrai pas à la
place de de Charles de Courson mais pour
en avoir beaucoup discuté avec lui
Charles de Courson considère que nous
sommes dans le cadre d'un départ de
l'âge légal de la retraite entre 62 et
67 ans n'est pas le pays où on parle le
plus tard le plus le plus tard le plus
tard à la retraite certains partent
jusqu'à 67 ans et qui avait une méthode
douce permettant de notre système de
retraite qui était un l'accélération de
la réforme Touraine et de rechercher des
moyens de
vous mêlez vos voix avec Monsieur
avec la France insoumise avec le
rassemblement national nous sommes un
groupe nous sommes un groupe central
ce groupe central il a joué évidemment
son rôle de catalyseur de l'ensemble des
oppositions à tel ou tel mais surtout
très pratique pour les autres
peut-être peut-être mais bon nous sommes
opposés à cet allongement de l'âge légal
de départ à la retraite parce que c'est
particulièrement injuste pour nos
concitoyens que nous rencontrons alors
en permanence nous avons des réponses en
termes de financement complémentaire et
surtout et surtout nous sommes le groupe
parlementaire du dialogue de la
concertation et le groupe parlementaire
des partenaires sociaux partenaires
sociaux vous êtes un peu si vous me
permettez l'expression un ovni quand
même parce que l'iode il faut dire ce
que ça veut dire liberté avec un S
indépendant avec un S outre-mer sans s
d’ailleurs alors que les outre-mer sont
variés quand même et
j'avais oublié territoires alors on
trouve des autonomistes corses avec des
anciens socialistes en rupture de banc
avec des centristes comment vous
expliquer que vous puissiez avoir une
harmonie une unité je l'explique parce
que nous pratiquons quotidiens ce que
personne ne pratique dans les trois
grandes formations politiques qui nous
dirigent et les filles l'extrême droite
ou Emmanuel Macron nous pratiquons
l'écoute le respect le dialogue et nous
sommes unis par une charte un vrai idéal
un idéal de développement humain
c'est-à-dire économique sociale
environnementale un développement pour
tous se manimer par une soif
d'épanouissement de tous par des par
l'autonomie et dans le cadre d'une
République solidaire c'est vraiment ce
qui fait notre colonne vertébrale et
pardon et pardon nous pensons que le
cadre est au moins aussi important que
le fond c'est à dire qu'à partir du
moment où on sait dialoguer on s'est
concerté on prend son temps pour écouter
les uns et les autres on arrive toujours
à des solutions c'est la raison pour
laquelle certains
nous ont peut-être pris pour des ovnis
mais quand un an après notre retour
d'expérience on se rend compte que notre
groupe parlementaire a très très souvent
les mêmes les comment les mêmes
positions je peux vous dire que sur le
terrain les Françaises et les Français
me disent c'est vraiment dommage s'il
vous plaît que ça ne fonctionne pas au
plan national comme vous fonctionnez
dans votre groupe parlementaire nous
sommes la solution au problème de demain
la solution de petites précisions est-ce
que vous
Bertrand pencher venant du Parti radical
vous êtes pour l'autonomie de la Corse à
nous sommes comme nous nous sommes pour
un statut un statut particulier pour un
statut particulier pour la colle
beaucoup beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
poussé nous sommes favorables sur notre
territoire national sur leur métropole
un réel choc de décentralisation mais
important il faut très rapidement les
tasses débarrasse de tout ce qui sait
pas faire ça fonctionnera beaucoup mieux
ça sera beaucoup moins coûteux et il
faut que pour les territoires qui sont
plus éloignés
besoin davantage de plus de plus qu'en
plus d'autonomie c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment la solution
l'indépendance après-demain quoi
pour être particulièrement ami avec mes
trois parlementaires Corse Gilles
Siméoni bon je peux vous dire que ce qui
est d'abord ce qui est ce qui est
important pour eux c'est l'autonomie
dans le cas de du respect de la du
respect de la République bon vous savez
qu'on va commencer à des statues comment
d'indépendance ces prochaines
institutions effectivement pour
évidemment mais notre une autre
disposition par exemple avec vos amis
socialistes qui sont dans votre groupe
eux ils sont évidemment pour le retour
de l'info ou sur la fortune est-ce que
c'est votre cas alors nous sommes
nous avons fait des propositions sur le
plan sur le plan fiscal pour faire en
sorte de pouvoir financer
évidemment notre régime notre système de
retraite et parmi les propositions que
nous faisons il y a notamment la
généralisation de la taxe sur les
transactions financières c'est le
Royaume-Uni qui a
misiane c'était un grand projet du
président de Macron un grand projet de
François Hollande d'un grand projet
Nicolas Sarkozy un grand projet de
François Hollande Emmanuel Macron est
arrivé en disant je veux récupérer la
Bourse de Londres à Paris c'est quand
même entre 5 et 6 milliards d'euros par
an qui pourraient permettre de régler
déjà une partie du financier
je ne pense pas que la spéculation pour
la spéculation fasse fuir quelques-uns
quand vous voyez que par exemple
suite notamment à la crise du covid nous
avons une augmentation du patrimoine des
milliardaires qui a pratiquement doublé
moi je pense que mettre un ou deux
points de 16g sur les sur les revenus
sur les revenus d'ailleurs à la faveur
d'un quart d'heure sur le intervenu du
patrimoine ça changerait pas grand chose
et d'ailleurs il y a des très riches qui
se disent bah tiens qui demandent même à
être prélevé un peu davantage je pense
que je vous en connaissais en France
vous pensez alors je vais vous écouter
tout à l'heure et vous disiez que
finalement le dialogue dans ce pays a
bien du mal à passer est-ce que vous
estimez qu'il faut une réforme
constitutionnelle le plus vite possible
alors moi je pense que il faut une
réforme constitutionnelle
je suis pas je suis pas on est tous sauf
des révolutionnaires la Cinquième
République permet beaucoup de choses la
Cinquième République aurait dû
d'ailleurs permettre à Emmanuel Macron
ou bien dissout de l'Assemblée nationale
ou bien d'avoir de faire de de mettre en
place un référendum puisque quand il y a
un grand dissensus entre le président de
la réartre l'exécutive président de la
République et la population c'est la
seule solution
et aussi nombreux sites général de
Gaulois je vais vous dire j'ai rien ne
me fait peur j'ai quatre mandats de
parlementaires dissolution bonne
dissolution parlementaires contre le
parti du président de la République
c'est ce qu'on dit une dissolution ça
donnerait beaucoup plus de députés
j'ai dit que interroger sur la capacité
sur la capacité de d'utiliser ou pas la
Constitution on peut faire beaucoup de
choses avec la Constitution je rappelle
je voulais je voulais répéter redire que
ce qui était vraiment très important
c'est de de pouvoir ondiguer cette vraie
rupture démocratique entre nos
concitoyens et et un pouvoir qui qui
semble de plus en plus éloignés d'eux
moi je crois et bien je fais ces trois
chocs un triple choc un choc de
décentralisation très forte
gagnant ça passe
au collectivité ça permet ça permet
d'éviter des doublons moi de vous donner
un exemple concret pour que nous ceux
qui celles et ceux qui nous écoutent
comprennent moi je pense réellement
qu'avec la moitié de moyens en matière
de logement de rénovation thermique et
un seul interlocuteur c'est à dire les
régions on obtiendrait on obtiendrait
les mêmes les mêmes résultats quand je
vois
tous ces morcellement d'intervention
dans tous les sens c'est inextricable ça
des responsabilités sous le monde
deuxièmement un choc d'écoute en
direction de nos concitoyens présidents
Macron s'était engagé pendant sa
campagne électorale a diminué le seuil
du référendum un million de signatures
et bien il faut qu'il le fasse il faut
que nos concitoyens
c'est une réforme il y a des réformes il
y a il peut y avoir des des
mesures qui font l'objet d'une de loi
simple et d'autres de réformes
constitutionnelles et puis troisièmement
et bien c'est un parlement qui qui
retrouve de la vigueur et du pouvoir et
pour ça il y a ou bien l'inversement du
calendrier présidentiel
c'est à dire on permettant des élections
législatives avant des élections
présidentielles soit la proportionnelle
si nous ne finalement on a une chambre
qui ressemble étroitement à une sortie
de proportionnelle là elle est quand
même très très morcelée d'abord il
faudrait que le Président de la
République le comprenne et il l'a pas il
l'a pas compris il faudrait que ça soit
obligé de faire un pratiques régulières
de façon à ce que quand un chef de
l'État est élu et bien le chef de l'État
se disent qu'il doit composer avec
toutes les forces politiques et bien il
faut instaurer tout ça et je vous
garantis que si on fait ça c'est à dire
si on réforme l'Assemblée nationale avec
un parlementaire plus fort on aura en
face de nous des Françaises et nous
Français nous disons mais vous savez
quelque chose si on le redonne les
moyens de s'exprimer à travers le
référendum et bien ils vont nous dire
oui bah cette démocratie elle est
fortifiée et aussi on accompagne tout ça
par un choc de de de décentralisation
avec des populations ayant en face de
des élus qui sont en responsabilité et
qui sont incapa en capacité de répondre
à leurs questions et bien notre pays
fonctionnera beaucoup beaucoup mieux
merci
vous nous avez pas dit si vous supprimez
le 49-3 pardon vous ne savez pas dit si
vous supprimez le
49-39-3 fait on pourrait très bien on
pourrait très très bien s'en passer
tout à l'heure effectivement s'il y
avait une dissolution le RN reviendrait
sans doute beaucoup plus nombreux c'est
ce que disent en tout cas les sondages
est-ce que vous n'avez pas l'impression
pardon l'expression mais d'être un peu
l'idiot utile de la nuque du RN avec
cette proposition de loi pour abroger la
réforme des retraites
il y a pas que le RN il y a également
des collègues et amis de LR et peut-être
y avoir aussi des des parlementaires
Renaissance je vais peut-être en
profiter de renaissance j'en discute
avec les uns et les autres tout le monde
n'est pas
n'est pas très très enjoué à l'idée de
allier d'aller voter une question sur
les soignants non vaccinés qui sont
réintégrés à partir d'aujourd'hui vous
avez voté récemment un texte communiste
pour cette réintégration c'est une
victoire pour vous aujourd'hui c'était
une forte demande de loutre-mer je
rappelle que il y a il faut c'était mes
collègues mes collègues d'outre-mer et
mes collègues mes collègues d'outre-mer
ont une particularité c'est les
médecines vraiment traditionnelles et on
a bien vu que en outre-mer il y avait
une vraie difficulté à faire imposer
cette vaccination obligatoire
s'entraîner des sanctions
ils sont face à des difficultés de
recruter des soignants bon il y a
maintenant un reflux un peu de la un peu
de la maladie et je pense que c'était de
de bon sens d'aller d'aller en cette
direction même dans le pays de pasteur
c'est pas
[Musique]
donc moi j'ai aucun problème avec la
vaccination la vaccination mais vous
savez ça sera intéressant un jour
d'organiser également un débat sur ce
refus également du progrès du progrès
scientifique pourquoi on est le seul
pratiquement à des seuls pays en Europe
en est comme ça c'est toujours pareil
parce qu'on est dans un État centralisé
qu'impose tout avec des concitoyens
qu'on peut flux quoi redonnons de la
Redon de la respiration à notre débat
enfin dans commandant nos débats les
sons nos concitoyens s'exprimer et vous
verrez qu'on passera
des controverses complètement
différentes voilà juste en face de vous
s'est installé Charles inston bonjour et
merci d'être avec nous bon ça vous êtes
député renaissance du Bas-Rhin et vous
aviez deux thèmes sur lesquels vous
souhaitiez interroger Bertrand pencher
les retraites et tchuss France vous
voulez commencer par quoi on va
commencer par lire très puisque je crois
que vous en avez parlé tout à l'heure
bonsoir Bertrand pencher bonsoir alors
moi je suis jeune député j'ai été lui il
y a quelques mois et je viens d'une
terre historiquement sans triste de la
démocratie chrétienne ou l'UDF a été
très longtemps je crois un parti que
vous vous connaissez bien alors moi
depuis plusieurs mois j'ai beaucoup
d'anciens amis l'UDF qui me pose cette
question que je vais relayer ici
pourquoi est-ce que des personnes comme
Bertrand Penchard et Charles de Courson
sa coquine avec l'extrême gauche contre
une réforme sérieuse qui est la réforme
des retraites historiquement la famille
à laquelle vous appartenez à toujours
soutenu voilà moi d'abord je voudrais
répondre que
nous nous a coquinons avec avec personne
signez nous nous représentons nous nous
sommes un groupe parlementaire
indépendant avec des élus ici et des
élus du des territoires et notre groupe
parlementaire joue son rôle je trouve
que ça serait quand même fort de café
qu'on puisse pas prendre position sur un
projet de loi de ce type qui est
important pour nous pour nos concitoyens
nos concitoyens nous interpellent nous
interpellent en permanence
j'ajoute que moi je le fais de façon
complètement transparente puisque
lorsque je me suis présenté aux
élections législatives j'ai dit à mes
concitoyens que j'étais opposé à cette
augmentation unie enfin uniforme de
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite donc
je suis c'est vraiment conforme à mes
engagements en ayant soutenu un mois
avant Valérie Pécresse qui défendait la
retraite
François Fillon qui j'ai écouté j'ai du
mal à comprendre ce genre de tête à
queue en quelque sorte
je pense que pour un pari je crois me
souvenir que vous étiez à
lrené aussi défendez défendez la
retraite à 65 ans
peut-être aussi en changeant
d'engagement politiquement enfin c'est
votre enfin c'est votre co évidemment
c'est votre c'est votre droit moi je ne
me suis jamais caché y compris pendant
dans la campagne présidentielle de mon
opposition à cette augmentation de l'âge
légal de la retraite parce que je vois
bien mes concitoyens qui n'en peuvent
plus mais être soignante mais aide à
domicile ma caissière de supermarchés
il y a quelques jours sur 7 graves
injustice je pense qu'il y avait
d'autres moyens de financer ce système
il suffisait d'écouter les organisations
syndicales je pense notamment la CFDT
qui était qui avait des propositions on
est à 15 milliards je sais pas si vous
vous rendez compte 15 milliards de
dépenses pendant combien avons-nous
aggraver la dette de la France ces
dernières années de 6 ans il y avait une
réforme de 600 de 600 milliards rétablir
les de 600 milliards avec des mesures
qui n'était pas forcément très très
juste on prive la France de recettes
fiscales de 50 milliards d'euros à
travers des tas d'exonération qu'on
aurait pu rendre plus juste c'est à dire
les cibler vers les populations les plus
en difficulté que de les faire de façon
complètement unilatérale et là 600
milliards de dettes c'est quand même pas
mal une crise 50 milliards mais on
aurait pu on aurait pu où nous avons
fait des propositions vous venez
d'arriver ici à l'Assemblée nationale
nous avons fait des propositions pour
cibler en direction des personnes qui en
avait le plus les plus besoin vous comme
moi bon la réforme des de la fiscalité
locale on aurait pu continuer à payer
nos impôts vous comme moi on aurait pu
continuer à payer la redevance
télévision bien je pense que nous avons
fait des propositions
nous avons fait des propositions nous
avons fait des propositions pour cibler
notamment ces ces exonérations ces
exonérations fiscales bon ça n'a pas été
le cas possible c'est 15 milliards je
rappelle que c'est 15 milliards dans le
pire des cas le corps 2030 on n'était
pas à quelques mois près pour trouver
une solution nous avons des propositions
la raison pour laquelle nous engageons
encore à relancer une conférence sociale
moi je pense qu'en prenant un peu de
temps on serait arrivé à cette solution
là et je pense que votre gouvernement et
votre majorité n'auraient pas été aussi
impopulaire si c'était donné un petit
peu le temps de la réflexion le passage
en force sa fragilise la démocratie si
la note de la France vient de baisser
c'est pas parce qu'on n'a pas réussi à
passer en force c'est parce qu'on est en
incapacité de réformer et d'écouter sur
sur les retraites l'autre sujet qui va
arriver dans trois semaines c'est donc
la proposition de loi que nous aurons à
discuter le 8 juin il y a un problème
majeur dans cette proposition là à mon
sens elle est en constitutionnel au
regard de l'article 40 de la
Constitution que connaissent pas
forcément tous nos concitoyens mais
c'est le moment de le dire qui dit très
clairement qu'une proposition de loi ne
peut pas aggraver les charges publiques
et là on parle de 15 milliards d'euros
qui ne sont pas financés voilà on a gagé
ça en termes techniques sur le tabac
voilà tout ça tout ça n'est pas très
sérieux donc moi j'aimerais que vous
nous comment
cette proposition de l'article 40 de la
constitutions
groupe qu'on aura au sein de la majorité
moi je considère que c'est proposition
de loi à 15 milliards d'euros qui n'est
pas financé elle est irrecevable au
titre de l'article 40 donc comment
est-ce que vous financez ces 15
milliards d'euros d'abord chers
collègues moi je vous dis le texte
moi je vous donnerai pas le conseil de
tenter de faire de l'obstruction
parlementaire sur un sujet non non mais
je vous le dis je vous le dis quand même
parce que vous allez allumer vraiment un
bâton de dynamite les Français sont
devant Brigitte il y a quelques jours
j'ai dit que moi je considérais que
c'était pas bonne politique
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment un bâton
de dynamite on est d'accord c'est les
Français veulent faire en sorte qu'on
aille jusqu'au bout et qu'on vote et
qu'on vote et moi je défends le
Parlement jamais jamais fait c'est mon
quatrième mandat de parlementaire jamais
j'ai vu une proposition de loi ou de
d'origine parlementaire où on a opposé
cet article 40 jamais alors si on change
le règlement parce que c'est le groupe
liotte qui dépose un projet de loi qui
embarrasse le gouvernement et sa
majorité je peux vous dire que le remède
va être plus que vont plus terrible que
le mal deuxième observation deuxième
observation nous nous faisons la
proposition d'une conférence sociale
pourquoi une conférence sociale parce
que les partenaires sociaux il faut les
mettre ensemble pour trouver des
solutions de financement et nous pensons
que nous pouvons à travers une
conférence sociale ouvrir des
possibilités de de financement de
calendrier regardez quand même cette
absurdité enfin c'est un truc
complètement dingue vous nous confirmer
que vous avez déposé un texte vous ne
savez pas comment le financer ce que
vous dites ce que vous voulez faire une
conférence sociale plus tard c'est un
peu c'est un peu prenez pas ne prenez
pas des des jeux comme ça
on parle de 15 milliards d'euros je suis
pas né de la dernière pluie on a fait
des propositions financement notre
système de retraite à travers à la fois
l'augmentation de la comment
l'augmentation de fin l'accélération de
la réforme Touraine c'est une idée des
pistes de complet de commandes d'épices
de financement complémentaires nous nous
voulons faire en sorte que la démocratie
sociale joue comment joue son rôle et
nous fasse des propositions vous allez
quand même pas me faire croire à un seul
moment d'y faire croire un seul moment
aux françaises aux Français qu'augmenter
deux ans la je départ à la retraite
alors qu'il y a déjà 40% de personnes de
chaude de chômeurs qui qui partent qui
partent en retraite sont un vaste plan
Seigneur qui a été par votre majorité
qui a été complètement rognée dans le
cadre de la navette de la navette
ça va revenir dans un projet loi travail
un débat de qualité à l'Assemblée
nationale qui a été en grande partie
obstruée par vos alliés du moment
d'extrême gauche on aurait peut-être pu
approfondir un peu plus ce sujet
de on n'était pas deux ou trois mois
près pour discuter ce 47 ans le
président l'a annoncé dans sa campagne
présidentielle il y a plus d'un enfant
deuxième tour des élections
présidentielles je vais commencer
d'ailleurs par finir leur par leur
gratter s'il continue comme ça j'ai voté
par Emmanuel Macron deuxième tour des
élections présidentielles alors que
parallèlement je m'étais engagé à ne pas
voter cette augmentation de l'âge légal
de départ retraite et il y en a beaucoup
qui ont été comme ça
par défaut pour Emmanuel Macron mais
contre la fin pas pour sa réforme des
retraites c'est ce que vous dites
et je vais vous dire chers collègues ça
serait un grand service si vous comme
les autres nous aidiés à faire en sorte
que cette loi passe parce que ça
permettrait de désenbourber la situation
du pays et pendant quatre ans de réussir
à mettre en place des réformes basées
sur le dialogue nous on ne demande que
ça à travailler il y aura un vote en
tout cas le 8 juin vous vous souhaitez
aller au vote
j'espère une réunion en tout cas demain
il y aura une stratégie et vous allez en
discuter dès demain il y avait un autre
thème sur lequel vous souhaitez
interroger Bertrand frangin sur tous
France qui avait lieu aujourd'hui à
Versailles de la République a explique
la cohérence de notre action économique
avec l'accent mission l'industrie et je
sais que par ailleurs je crois que vous
êtes un spécialiste des questions
d'environnement donc vous avez peut-être
vu le discours qui qu'il a commis à
quelques jours et donc où il l'explique
l'importance
d'accélérer la transition énergétique
par par l'industrie donc il y aura un
texte industrie verte qui arrivera à
l'Assemblée dans quelques jours semaine
donc voilà comment est-ce que vous vous
envisagerez vous vous ce texte ce que
vous le considérez important est-ce que
vous reconnaissez aussi voilà que sur
l'industrie nous avons réussi à arrêter
en tout cas l'hémorragie et à faire
repartir aussi la dynamique industrielle
de notre pays ça m'intéresserait de vous
entendre là-dessus oui c'est un texte
qui est effectivement important je pense
qu'il faut essayer de faire revenir des
grandes entreprises et réindustrialiser
notre pays je pense qu'on part quand
même très loin que je pense que le
il échappe à personne que le déficit
commercial n'a jamais été aussi
important dans notre pays je crois le
pire déficit commercial depuis 1945
comme on semble-t-il bon après je mets
en garde les uns et les autres de faire
des cocorico je pense qu'il faut aussi
pouvoir rester modeste c'est bien de
s'engager dans cette direction il y a
encore beaucoup de réformes à faire
peut-être que j'aurais pas conseillé non
plus à Emmanuel Macron d'organiser une
réception à Versailles pour ce que
l'image vis-à-vis de nos concitoyens et
peut-être pas la meilleure
en
[Musique]
communications internationaux et pour
les pour les étrangers c'est vrai que
Versailles est un des lieux symboliques
du pays et pour attirer des gens qui
vont investir des millions voir parfois
des centaines de millions d'euros
Versailles est un lieu voilà qui qui qui
n'est pas neutre et qui est symbolique
et qui fonctionne manifestement
sur cette question de l'industrie verte
vous avez de quoi un peu plus précise
parce que dans ce cas d'île président il
y a quelques jours il a notamment parlé
de crédit d'impôt que nous pourrions
être amené à créer pour favoriser les
investissements dans les batteries les
pompes à chaleur les éoliennes les
panneaux solaires de créer une sorte de
crédit d'impôt industriel verte est-ce
que vous pensez voilà c'est quelque
chose qui va qui va dans le bon sens aux
gens de discuter nous avons discuté avec
Bruno Le Maire c'est bon c'est
effectivement des propositions qui vont
dans le format moi je suis pas là pour
tout critiquer quand même
ça veut dire que la
ce projet de loi industrie verte déjà il
faut déjà que nous en discutions nous
ont discutons ensemble
il faut évidemment tout faire en sorte
pour réindustrer liser notre pays
voir également combien coûte cette
accompagnement financier parce que les a
parlé je crois de 20 milliards
commandent 20 milliards d'euros moi je
me méfie toujours avec les promesses
financières
il faut regarder ensuite comment nous
allons pouvoir décliner décliner tout ça
parce que le gouvernement sait faire à
travers des des sommes qui sont parfois
difficiles donc on va demander
évidemment pouvoir tracer ces dépenses
et ses engagements pour pour les
entreprises
on va on va étudier ce texte là le
moment venu j'attire quand même votre
attention sur le fait que on s'était
engagé à
concerter
tous les groupes parlementaires dans le
cadre des projets de loi de futurs pour
celui-là malheureusement on vient de
nous présenter sans que nous ayons été
associés en amont à cet ex de loi donc
c'est la raison pour laquelle on est
pour le moins un petit peu prudent sur
nos prises de position merci Charles
d'avoir été avec nous et d'avoir posé
ces questions à Bertrand pencher une
petite question subsidiaire Bertrand
pencher si votre texte est voté mais que
le gouvernement ne suspend pas les
décrets d'application est-ce que vous
déposerez une motion de censure
on en est pas on est pas là pour le
moment enfin chaque temps chaque temps
suffit sa peine moi je pense que ça
serait vraiment une très très grave
erreur pour Emmanuel Macron de ne rien
bouger de ne rien bouger après tout ça
vous savez
mon fantasme c'est pas ma taille midi et
soir de me dire mais ce qu'on va ou pas
en fond de renverser le gouvernement
fantasme c'était en sorte que la fin le
on puisse nous engager dans des dans des
réformes qui sont des réformes bon sens
dans le pays et travailler ensemble et
ce qui est malheureusement pour le ment
pas le cas alors
on va voir tes missions en
direct réseau sociaux
je regarde où là oui une question sur
les réseaux sociaux mais peut-être une
précision puisqu'on parlait tout à
l'heure des des armes données par la
France des armes que de la France doit
donner ce soir Emmanuel Macron confirme
que la France va former des pilotes
Ukrainiens ça c'était par rapport à ce
qu'on se disait tout à l'heure moi j'ai
une question sur également sur les
réseaux sociaux un certain nombre de
députés insoumis et rassemblements
national ce sont mis sur Tik Tok
question Bertrand vancher est-ce que
vous y êtes est-ce que vous comptez y
être est-ce le moyen
d'arracher les jeunes à l'abstention
RAF alors je suis pas sur Tik Tok
parce que j'ai quand même beaucoup de
difficultés à gérer tous les tous les
réseaux tous les réseaux sociaux je suis
sur Facebook et sur Twitter
c'est un moyen pour moi quand même
beaucoup d'informer mes électeurs et
c'est important c'est pas pour moi le
moyen
d'organiser un débat et
et c'est vraiment pas l'alpha et l'oméga
d'une démocratie apaisée je préside un
grand sing-tang qui s'appelle décidait
ensemble qui a pour objectif de
développer en France une culture de la
décision partagée avec des rencontres
très comment très très prochainement
à Rouen en juin comment je juin prochain
on aura à peu près 15 500 acteurs
pendant trois jours et nous allons
mettre la question de la thématique des
des réseaux sociaux c'est-à-dire comment
faire en sorte que les réseaux sociaux
soient
rentrent dans le cadre d'une d'une
culture non seulement de l'information
mais du dialogue je crois qu'il y a
beaucoup de choses à faire et faisons
vraiment très très attention de
continuer à nous appuyer sur sur une
presse une presse spécialisée des médias
sans lesquels cette transparence ce
n'est pas des informations n'est pas en
permanence vérifiée
merci Vincent roux d'avoir été avec nous
en direct menace la démocratie je pense
pas que les je ne pense pas que les
réseaux sociaux menacent je pense pas
que les réseaux sociaux menacent la
démocratie mais les réseaux sociaux
comme comme l'écriture comme la primerie
comme la radio comme la télévision on
était générateurs de nouvelles formes de
d'expressions démocratique dont il faut
tenir compte et en tout cas il faut
avoir le recul pour travailler avec ces
outils dont on ne pourra pas se passer
merci Vincent roux
pour former des pilotes de chats
Ukrainiens est-ce que vous pensez qu'il
faut un débat sur le crâne ici au
Parlement
il y a eu sur on a déjà eu beaucoup de
débats sur le sujet la forme la
formation enfin je pense qu'il y a eu
vraiment une grande majorité de
parlementaires
très favorable au soutien de la France
et l'Ukraine merci Bertrand a été notre
invité président du groupe lyaute vous
défendrez votre proposition de loi le 8
juin dans l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée
nationale un débat à suivre évidemment
dans son intégralité sur LCP merci à
vous tous de nous avoir suivi
[Musique]